we begin this morning with the decision
that sent shockwaves across america the
supreme court ending constitutional
protection for abortions by overturning
roe versus wade in a landmark decision
friday the court's five most
conservative justices struck down the
nearly 50-year-old ruling and a 1992
case that reaffirmed the right to an
abortion the decision in this new case
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization sends the issue of abortion
rights back to the states and it's
likely to result in abortion bans in
about half while the supreme court's
decision is a victory long sought by
abortion opponents the ruling was met
with outrage by abortion rights
advocates
protests spread from the steps of the
high court to cities across the country
and demonstrations are planned in more
than 100 cities throughout the weekend
at a protest in phoenix last night
police used tear gas to scatter
demonstrators police say the protesters
were banging on the windows of the state
capitol while the senate was in session
there there were no injuries or arrests
we have a team of correspondents
covering the seismic decision and we
begin with christina rafini who is
outside the supreme court christina good
morning
good morning dana in the end the court's
decision closely resembled that leaked
draft opinion with a conservative
majority including those three justices
appointed by former president trump
voting to overturn nearly 50 years of
precedent the question now is what the
court is poised to do next
this decision must not stop this is
going to be like history this is just
the beginning of you know the pro-life
generation elation and anguish outside
the supreme court as the landmark
decision was handed down writing for the
majority justice samuel alito said the
constitution does not confer a right to
abortion returning the right to ban or
allow abortion to individual states
abortion remains fully legal in
california
today's decision does not
impact our state's laws we are prepared
to immediately ban abortion in arkansas
with the overturn of roe versus wade 26
states have petitioned the court to
overturn roe 13 already have laws on the
books that would ban abortion almost
immediately the others are poised to ban
or greatly restrict it it's a sad day
for the court and for the country
president biden said the court's
decision will put women's lives and
health at risk
it was three justices named by one
president donald trump
were the core of today's decision on
capitol hill house republican leader
kevin mccarthy praised the decision
this great nation can now live up to its
core principle
that all are created equal
not born equal created equal but speaker
nancy pelosi questioned if the court's
trump appointed justices had
misrepresented their position on roe to
congress were they not telling the truth
then
republican susan collins who voted for
neil gorsuch and brett kavanaugh
released a statement saying that both
nominees were insistent on the
importance of supporting long-standing
presidents like grow america is not
ready for what's about to happen with
the fall abroad
they're not abortion is now illegal in
at least seven states including oklahoma
where medical staff performing the
procedure could face prison time and at
least eight of the trigger law states do
not have exceptions for rape or incest
alexis mcgill johnson is the head of
planned parenthood for many patients it
means that they will be forced into
pregnancy because they won't be able to
have the resources or the ability to get
out of state teresa brennan is president
of the right to life league i believe
these are people and
they have rights too so we've got to
kind of find we have to find a way to
honor women but also
uh really protect the fundamental rights
of these children and in their
dissenting opinion the court's three
liberal justices warned whatever the
exact scope of the coming laws one
result of today's decision is certain
the curtailment of women's rights and of
their status as free and equal citizens
justice thomas who voted with the
majority wrote his own concurring
opinion
in which he suggested other rights like
gay marriage and the right to
contraception should also be reexamined
jeff
christina thank you very much